let's say that f of x
is equal to one over x and we want to
think about what the limit of f of x is
as x approaches zero from the positive
direction to think about this i'm going
to set up a little table here so let's
set up x
and then let's think about what f of x
is going to be
what f of x is going to be and i'm going
to approach x i'm going to approach a 0
from the positive direction so let's say
we'll try 0.1
then we're going to try
0.01
then we can try
0.001 then we could try
0.0001 so notice each of these numbers
they're all larger than than 0 and
they're approaching 0 from the positive
direction we're getting closer and
closer and closer to 0.
so when x is 0.1 f of x is just going to
be 1 over this this is 1 10 so 1 over
that is just going to be 10.
one over point one over zero point zero
one is going to be
one hundred one over zero point zero
zero one is going to be
one thousand one over
zero point zero zero zero zero
one is going to be 10 000.
10 000. so you see as x gets closer and
closer to zero from the positive
direction f of x just really grows
really really fast so what we say here
is the limit of f of x as x approaches 0
from the positive direction is going to
be equal to
positive infinity or we could just write
infinity this thing over here if we put
something really really close so if we
say
four 0.12345
six
seven digits behind the decimal place
then one over that's going to be
one
with one two three four
five six seven
zeros did i do that right here i had
four places behind the decimal four
zeros here i have one two three four
five six seven and here i have seven
zeros so you see as we get closer and
closer to zero from the positive
direction the f of x just gets larger
and larger and larger it's just
completely unbounded so we'd say this is
equal to
infinity well let's think about another
limit let's think about the limit
the limit as x approaches zero from the
negative direction of f of x or the
limit of f of x as x approaches zero
from the negative direction
well in that case we can just make each
of these values negative so if x is
negative zero point
zero point one this is going to be
negative ten if this is negative then
this is negative this is negative and
this is negative if this is negative
then this is negative if this is
negative then this is negative and so
what we see here is that this gets more
and more
becomes larger and larger numbers in the
negative direction we still keep going
if we're thinking about a number line
further and further and further to the
left so we can say the limit of f of x
as x approaches 0 from the negative
direction
is equal to
negative infinity
well that's interesting now let's think
about a limit as x approaches either
positive or negative infinity so let's
now think about the limit
the limit of f of x
as x approaches infinity and one way to
set up this table we can just say
we can just say do a similar thing x
and
x and f of x so if f if x is
10 then f of x is 1 over 10. if x is and
i'm just going to go larger and larger
numbers if x is less one thousand then f
of x is one over
one thousand if x is one million
one million
then f of x is going to be one millionth
one
millionth so you see as x gets larger
and larger and larger in the positive
direction this f of x now gets closer
and closer and closer to zero so we can
say the limit of f of x as x approaches
infinity is equal to
zero
now let's think about the limit
the limit of f of x as x
approaches negative infinity so we're
going to take we're going to take
numbers that are more and more and more
negative well if x is negative 10 this
is going to be negative 1 10. if x is
negative 1 000 this is going to be
negative 1 over 1 000. if this is
negative 1 million it's going to be
negative 1 millionth but we still see
that we are approaching 0. so here once
again we are once again approaching 0.
so what implications does this have
besides that we've just been able to
deal with limits and once again i
haven't given you a formal definition of
this but it's hopefully giving you an
intuition as we take limits to infinity
to negative infinity actually this is
supposed to be negative infinity limits
to infinity limits to negative infinity
or when our limit itself is infinity or
negative infinity so one we're seeing
that we can do that but let's actually
try to visualize this and when we look
at the graph of f of x is equal to 1
over x
so let's do it actually maybe i want to
i want to be able to keep looking at all
of this stuff so let me set up the graph
let me set up the graph right over here
so that's our x-axis
this right over here is our y-axis
and let's graph f of x
so we see that as x gets if x is very
small number if like x is 0.1 then y y
is equal to f of x is going to be a very
high number and as the closer and closer
we get to 0 the closer and closer we get
to 0 from the positive direction f of x
approaches infinity so it just keeps
approaching infinity as we get closer
and closer to 0 as x gets closer and
closer to zero the y value just gets
higher and higher
then as our x value gets larger and
larger our y our f of x value gets
smaller and smaller so it gets smaller
and smaller so it looks something like
that it approaches 0.
similarly if we approach
if we approach x from the negative
direction right over here we saw that f
of x is approaching negative infinity
approaches negative infinity so as we
get x is closer and closer to zero our f
of x gets more and more and more
negative
and then as our x becomes becomes cl
becomes
more and more negative the x itself
becomes more and more negative we see
that our function is approaching zero is
approaching 0. so the way i've drawn it
we see that there's actually two
asymptotes for the graph of f of x is
equal to 1 over x you have a horizontal
asymptote at y is equal to 0.
you have a horizontal asymptote at y is
equal to zero
when we when x approaches infinity it
gets close f of x gets closer and closer
to zero but never quite touches it when
x when x approaches negative infinity
f of x is approaching is getting closer
and closer to zero from the bottom but
it never quite touches it and we also
have a vertical asymptote we have a
vertical asymptote right over here at x
is equal to zero
and we see that because as x approaches
zero from the positive direction
y
approaches infinity and as x approaches
0 from the negative direction y
approaches negative infinity so in the
limit here at x is equal to 0. so if you
were to say we looked at the limit as x
approaches zero from the positive
direction and from the negative
direction but we see that they're
approaching two different things so we
definitely have a vertical asymptote at
x is equal to zero but the limit
the limit as x approaches zero of f of x
this is not defined
not defined
why is that well when we approach 0 from
the positive direction we get a
different thing than when we approach it
from the negative direction